How Much Caffeine Would it Take to Kill You?
There are several factors that make this a
tricky question.
Not everyone reacts the same way to caffeine.
People also become tolerant to it and so the
effects can be different from person to person.
Lastly, there would be no respectable researcher
who would dare perform a study on humans,
if the goal of that study is death to that
same person.
All that being said, there are some very good
studies that have allowed doctors to understand
what’s going on inside the body in caffeine
overdoses.
They also have been able to presume the approximate
dose that would prove fatal for the average
person.
So while the exact dose is almost impossible
to answer for a given individual, I can tell
you the highest caffeine dose ever ingested
by someone who survived was a mere 100 grams.
Although that might not sound like that much,
in terms of raw amount of caffeine, it should
be noted that that’s the amount of caffeine
in about 1,200 cups of coffee!
While lesser doses would probably kill many,
we can safely say that’s around the upper
bar.
So you might now be wondering how exactly
caffeine can be fatal to a person, in terms
of what exactly is going on in the body when
high doses of caffeine are ingested.
Caffeine is one of several naturally occurring
substances known as Xanthines.
Xanthines are among other things, central
nervous system (CNS) stimulants.
Caffeine, specifically, is in over 60 known
plant species.
It’s the most widely consumed psychoactive
substance in the world.
Depending on which study you read, approximately
80-90% of the US population consumes at least
200mg per day.
In low doses, it has many benefits that can
help with things like pain management, water
retention, alertness, and a general feeling
of wellbeing, to name a few.
As with most CNS stimulants, the higher the
dose, the more profound the reaction.
As you consume more caffeine, the risks begin
to outweigh the benefits.
A person can become jittery, anxious, begin
having high blood pressure, chest pain, headaches,
dehydration, and unfortunately, dependence
that causes withdrawals if you don’t continue
consuming it.
In toxic doses, caffeine can cause extremely
low blood pressures, seizures, cardiac rhythm
problems, and lactic acidosis.
While there appears to be some dissension
among researchers as to exactly how xanthines,
like caffeine, cause the reactions they do.
What is known is that they antagonize what
are known as adenosine-receptors within almost
every cell in the body.
Adenosine is a chemical present in every human
cell.
It combines with other chemicals like phosphate
to create numerous compounds that help cells
work properly.
Those compounds need to attach to their receptors
to affect cells.
There are 4 main groups of adensonine receptors
within the body and their effects can fall
into four categories.
Generally speaking, adenosine compounds help
in increasing the oxygen available to cells,
protect against the damage caused by a lack
of oxygen, help in initiating the body’s
natural anti-inflammatory responses, and help
in the creation of blood vessels.
Caffeine is similar to adenosine in chemical
composition, and as such, can attach to adenosine
receptors not allowing adenosine compounds
to perform normally.
The result is CNS and cardiac stimulation,
relaxation of the smooth muscles, and a diuretic
action on the kidneys that can lead to dehydration.
Thus, in high levels, caffeine can be very
toxic.
It will bind to adenosine receptor sites known
as subtypes A1 and A2.
The result is seizures.
In high doses, it will also inhibit an enzyme
known as phosphodiesterase, while stimulating
the release of neurotransmitters involved
in your fight or flight nervous system.
The result is extremely fast heart rates,
dilation of your blood vessels causing low
blood pressures, low potassium levels that
can cause lethal heart rhythms, the breakdown
of sugars in your liver, and an increase in
your white blood cells.
If all that doesn’t seem like it’s deadly
enough, those side effects will cause their
own problems.
Specifically, lactic acidosis will be caused
by your body’s tissues not getting enough
oxygen because your blood pressure is too
low.
The result of your seizures, low oxygen levels
within your cells, and an inevitable calcium
release from an area of your cells called
your endoplasmic reticulum will give you what
is known as rhabdomyolysis- this is a breakdown
of your muscles causing a release of your
muscle fibers into your bloodstream (brown
pee and clogged kidneys anyone!).
If you’re thinking “I’m never drinking
that nectar from Satan again”, don’t worry,
those toxic reactions won’t happen at normal
consumption levels.
Don’t just take my word for it; according
to the FDA, moderate amounts of caffeine,
around 100-200mg a day is not harmful.
They are quick to point out, however, that
caffeine will affect people differently based
on weight, sex, age, and sensitivity.
They also state that 600mg or more per day
is not recommended.
So unfortunately, when it comes to caffeine,
I can’t tell you the exact dose that will
kill you, other than to say the highest known
dose survived by anyone to date is about 100g.
I will, however, repeat the advice that works
for just about anything you choose to put
in your body, “everything in moderation”.
If you decide you want to consume 4 energy
drinks and follow it with 3 chocolate bars
and some Starbucks coffee ice cream, anxiety,
chest pain, and headaches are what you can
expect, at the least.
That and an increased waist size!